what did he do to make this house so
evil murder
vampirism cannibalism drug addiction
alcoholism Saders of mutilation how did
it end if it had ended we would not be
here
alright we're doing another movie review
already legend of Hell House oh my god
I'm so excited about this and you'd see
okay you know what's funny about this is
that I told you on the last movie review
that we did which was Logan's Run that
we had a huge I have a huge legal pad
you guys don't even know that's probably
like a hundred yeah movies are there at
least yeah and there's another one we
got to add to this too yeah yeah I want
I want to watch the front I want to do
the frighteners oh that's a good idea
very underrated a [ __ ] yeah I love the
frighteners it has a lot of stuff has a
lot of references to parapsychology and
ghosts yeah like that did a lot of tons
of work oh man anything I remember that
man and that's one of the reasons why
we're doing this is your choice legend
to hell yeah but legend to hell house
actually is pretty true to
parapsychology yeah that was one of the
things I would like to edit and the
arguments that have been going on within
parapsychology for a long long time
yeah oh you know is this phenomenon or
ghostly phenomenon is it a manifestation
of Chee or you know I mean energies that
come from humans or channeled by humans
or are they coming from the dead that's
right really what the shows yeah that's
like the essential kind of conflict
that's at the center of legend of health
but as I was saying I had totally
forgotten like I put the haunting from
1963 because that's one of my favorite
horror movies ever and I had that on the
list but I totally forgot to put legend
of Hell house on there even though it's
a similar film yeah to a haunting if you
know it's a couple years newer but
actually the novel that it's based on
which was written by Richard Matheson
and Richard Matheson also wrote the
screenplay for the movie the novel is
actually his version of Shirley Jackson
haunting of Hill House on which a
haunting was based so it's a similar
premise his book is just this
monumentally sexed-up version of it
although the movies owned a lot of that
down yeah I think this movie also was
kind of a template from which other
ghost movies were pull
from you know are built on like the evil
it reminds me a lot of yeah which we are
probably going to do a minor code I
really like that movie actually I feel a
little bit underrated to a little bit
like the movie the legacy - yeah another
one we wanted to rhyme oh yeah so it's
just it's funny that we remembered to
put all those movies on the list but I'm
like I can't believe I forgot Legend of
Hell House because I must have seen that
movie a hundred times right this is this
movie's a really good crash course in
the arguments that's been going on
between Eric that have been going on
inside parapsychology and ghost hunting
for a long long time so yeah it's a good
crash course yeah it really is in an
entertaining setting and yeah it's kind
of cool because I mean I must say like I
love horror movies of all kinds I mean
it's you know as long as they're good I
like shitty Wednesday we ended up
depending but probably my favorite
sub-genre of horror movies is haunted
house movies I [ __ ] love hot it out
memories and this is one of my favorite
haunted house with easily one of my
favorite haunted house movies of the 70s
yeah and doesn't really feel like a 70s
movies it really doesn't it's very I
mean it's British now the book it was
based on like I said it's Richard
Matheson so he's an American but and the
book was actually said in Maine but the
movie is set in England yeah and has all
British actors yeah with two hotties in
it yeah yeah and what's his name and
Roddy McDowall rotting
I love Roddy McDowall honest I really
must say I did well I loved him and
everything but yeah so legend of Hell
House it came out 1973 as I said it was
based on the book by Richard Matheson
which is just called Hell house that
came out in 1971 now Richard Matheson
also wrote the screenplay for the movie
so the book and the movie are pretty
similar the only things that are left
out of the movie were like in the movie
they kind of talked about the guy who
owned the house Emeric Belasco and how
he was this big pervert like
sadomasochists Ella so he's kind of like
an Aleister Crowley type of figure I
guess you know with all this mutilation
and torture and orgies and all this kind
of stuff going on in the house now in
the book I think it's that's a lot more
described you know what I mean like it's
really laid out and described in the
movie it's just kind
have referred to sort of not you know
it's like little kids can watch this
it's not really that they just let you
know there's a that the house is owned
by a pervy old yeah there is it implied
ghost rape but they don't really know it
there's a lot of like hot moves titty
statues hot cities - yeah you watch the
movie okay I love the made hot city yeah
definitely this is a big strong sexual
undercurrent not only in the film the
dialogue but also in the decor of the
house yeah and like I said the book the
reason the movie is like that because
the book was much more overt yeah
supposedly owned by it kind of like a
sorcerer named Belasco and Belasco was
he was kind of like a cross between
Aleister Crowley and Hugh Hefner yeah
God in the book I think they implied too
that he was [ __ ] his sister most
other things are and you know have you
know women would have babies they would
eat them and all that kind of I think
that was that was a slide over my
beautiful no I think that was in the
book they look like I said the book is a
lot worse than the movie so the movie is
like fairly kind of low but yeah it's
fairly tame but some of that is still in
there by implication you know they did
say cannibalism yes extra cannibalism
that's for there yeah this movie was
heavily sampled by the Industrial Gothic
industrial band Skinny Puppy that's
right
yeah especially early Skinny Puppy yeah
they took one just one concept church in
hell yeah lifted that from that movie in
the middle song of a whole hog got a
caller charge in now yeah thought it was
on an EP yeah yeah Skinny Puppy Church
and hell there you go but yeah so
basically the setup of the movie is
similar to the setup of the haunting
from 1963 which I'm not going to go too
much into the similarities between those
two things because I want to do a whole
show on the haunting because like I said
that's probably my favorite or Moebius
60s one of my favorite horror movies is
sixties you really you get just like a
really short set up basically there's an
old guy who has all the money his name
is Rudolph Deutsche I think and he's
dying and there's a haunted house called
Hell House or the Belasco house and it's
supposedly the most haunted house in the
world in the movie they call it the
Mount Everest of haunted houses
it's been sealed up like 20 years yeah
it's been sealed up for 20 years now
this old guy Deutsch it's not real it's
really it's not actually just a house it
looks like a damn castle it is it is a
real house I mean the exterior they use
I can't remember the name of the house
I'd have to look it up on Wikipedia but
it is an actual manor house I don't know
if they use the same house for the
interiors and the exterior
probably not but in Jersey but they are
actually real houses so Deutsch is dying
and he says okay well I'm going to use
my you know copious funds yeah to
investigate the possibility of life
after death yeah your gadget l-look your
salary is 200 thousand pounds well yeah
well it was a hundred thousand worth of
value per person per person right just
tells him that he was oh okay which
those of them is a lot of cash back then
yeah well still a [ __ ] I wouldn't pay
yeah I said I don't care how hard the
hell did for a hundred thousand pounds
[ __ ] yeah I'll go to sleep in there sure
and he's basically like I wanted answer
within a week cuz you know how rich guys
are they kind of like to do that good
personality survive after that yeah go
find that [ __ ] up er yeah well because
he says this house being the most
haunted house in the world this is the
only house where it has yet to be
refuted I think that's the wording that
they use okay
so evidently the main guy or like the
head of the group is named Lionel
Barrett and he's a physicist but also a
pair of psychologist and his big thing
like his big theory and he's hoping that
his time at Hell House is going to prove
this is that he does not believe that
people's personalities survive beyond
death he does believe in the paranormal
but he thinks that it's just random
unfocused unintelligent energy yeah that
can be neutralized mechanically or
channeled by mediums or channeled by
medium right so he's not saying that all
of this [ __ ] is [ __ ] he's just
saying that he doesn't think it's an
intelligent personality or a ghost
quote-unquote it's kind of what we
believe yeah like I said so he's kind of
he's a lot douchier about it yeah yeah
he's a douche and actually in the book
he is a complete turd okay so he's as
snotty and like as the snotty prick as
he is in the movie he's like a hundred
times worse and the remote he's like
just a total [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
he's the main guy now he's going with
his wife in the movie she's named Ann
and the book she's named etus I don't
know why they changed that but whatever
and there are also two mediums now one
of the mediums is named Fisher and he's
played by Roddy McDowall now he is a
physical medium yeah which I guess like
I said I don't know if people know about
like old-school parapsychology or like
old school like seance mediums and stuff
like that
a physical medium is just one bit you
move things that can move things and
also produces physical phenomena like
ectoplasm and things like that and Roddy
McDowall is at his PC asbestos movie I
love him too so budgeted this yeah well
because you haven't seen it in a long
time right and like we were watching it
last night and it sounds like why Friday
McDowell being such a douche and I said
okay well one he has kind of a reason as
I call him a [ __ ] you did yes I am in
it but it's such a business but he had a
good reason and honestly like the head
like I said Lionel like the head of the
crew there I mean he seemed kind of like
well I'm correct and you guys are just
meeting of whatever I just don't think
it's any thought about so you know you
can see there was like a lot of tension
between the people which is one of the
things that's good about the movie like
all the tension between the characters
Roddy McDowall aside from being a
physical medium was also the only person
that lived well at first they said he
was the only one that survived the last
investigation of yellow house now some
people from the past ones did survive
but they were insane yeah he describes
how they went down people being
paralysed people crawling and you know
losing their limbs [ __ ] mostly leg
attacks yeah which is which is a
significant later on later on but so he
was the only one to survive that wasn't
physically harmed and also came out
mostly psychologically okay yeah and I
think the last one was 20 years
previously right it okay
so locked up for 20 years but they just
throw the doors wide open and girl
in their yard even firewood well Deutsch
the guy that in the wheelchair that was
talking to them he had bought the house
okay for the express purpose of hiring
piazza find out that's why that's why
was preserved yes and he so he had been
taking care of it and he was the one to
put all the food in there and you know
in the book you got people coming by
like bringing them food and like doing
things like that in the movie you don't
get any of that there didn't there for
like a week and they didn't I guess they
didn't have to do much to seal it up
because Belasco himself had all the
windows bricked up from the inside so no
one could see then Laura or out right
because of all the debauchery right yeah
he didn't want any but it's not like it
was like the house is way out in the
middle of nowhere it's not like anyone's
just gonna wander up and like peeking
the windows go by you know what I mean
it's not like that's going to happen but
anyway he was paranoid I suppose the
fourth member of the team is a mental
medium named Florence tanner God who has
played by Pamela Franklin and she is
cute as a button
I swear to God and I don't even know
like I should check her IMDB page I
never remember seeing her at any other
movie she is [ __ ] adorable I don't
know at she was scholars yeah oh and she
looked all proto god channel or silver
necklaces and all the rings and
everything like that I think that the
way they were talking about her and this
like even before she was introduced like
the way Lionel was talking about her is
like oh she's just a child or something
like that but he does look quite young
yeah she's must be younger than me but I
think she was supposed to be like I
think they were implying that she was
like 17 or 18 but I mean she actually
looked about 23 24 something like that
she did look quite young but not like a
baby so the central conflict of the
movie is kind of between Lionel Barrett
who has built this machine that he's
saying is going to neutralize all this
random unfocused energy that's causing
the haunting and between mostly Florence
tanner who believes that all of the
manifestations are caused by a ghost or
ghost so that's kind there's like a lot
of conflict between all the people now
it comes to light later on that Roddy
McDowall I mean because for a while
nothing really happens to Roddy McDowall
like he just kind of comes in and walks
around like a moon cool okay and he
seems alright now when they first go in
the house
and they're walking around since Ronnie
McDowell has been there before like
Lionel's like oh what's this down here
is that the cellar blah blah blah and
he's like what's that down there he's
like that's the chapel yeah and so
they're like in hell yes because it has
like it has like a it's all you look it
kind of does look like a real chapel but
isn't there like the Jesus figure it
kind of looks like a go / like a devil
kind of figure on there instead of Jesus
no I think it was just a ruler Jesus
from what I remember it's just funny
looking I thought it's like a good
whatever the sets look really good it's
like yeah I mean the house that they
filmed within I want that house I almost
feel bad with spoilers with this one why
I hate because ever feeling that a lot
of our subs ourselves well I'll actually
see if you haven't seen it then turn it
off right now because I'm gonna join and
while the [ __ ] out there showing it on
Netflix yeah it's not Netflix watch it
yeah so if you haven't seen it turn it
off go watch it on Netflix and then come
back then come back because of the kind
of movie that it is yeah you have to let
it unveil itself through yeah I think it
was ears even you know yeah I mean
seriously if you're into like kind of
slow burned ghost haunted house movies
like the seventies and if you haven't
seen it you really need to say yeah it's
a classic and the phenomenon that it
shows and the things that happened are
kind of true to life to the really good
poltergeist / ghost cases
yeah they weren't they're not inventing
stuff they're actually just using the
things that were reported from other
cases
yeah the tremor rings and things you
know in mild cases of possession going
on yeah there was a little bit of
pyrokinesis I think that happened there
was ectoplasm that happened which even
in mind with the blue mist in my case
the blue haze I think maybe an early
medium pro you know like an 1800
immediately I would have thought that
that was ectoplasm
yeah but photographs of actual ectoplasm
from seances that we've all seen you
know this [ __ ] fake that's cheese
cloth this cheese cloth or cotton and
[ __ ] yeah they're putting cotton up in
cheesecloth up in the veg good out it
was cotton that's confirmed yeah they
have bought some of the mediums doing
that yeah cheese cloth in the veg
no I'm not gonna talk about it yet
because there was a certain odor that
was familiar yeah it's like we're but
they were you know then they want to
rationalize it well you know it's a
pleasant you know it capella exudes from
the body in there and the mouth and it's
you know it's part of the human body so
it smells you know no gosh stuffs up in
the bag and you're funny because you're
acting all gross out even though you're
the one that brought it there it is
hilarious because for real the ectoplasm
is that is manifested alleged of Hell
House actually doesn't look like doesn't
are cheap super it doesn't look like
she's off it it kind of just looks like
lights kind of like a like a lighted
kind of thing coming out we have a very
good ambiance to it that other horror
movies tried to copy yeah if you watch
the evil which is another good movie yes
I like that movie I did say evil was
trying to capture the same feeling as
the movie legend of Hell House yeah if
you watch them both you'll see what I'm
talking something I noticed that I had
never noticed before that we were
watching it last night and I don't know
if they did this on purpose
legend of Hell House one it doesn't
really have much of a background score
there's some kind of oboe we music like
at the beginning and at the end but
there is yeah during the movies runtime
there's not much background music I
think that might make it feel a little
more intense that's what I mean and I
thought that and I was like that must
have been you know a deliberate decision
also they hadn't had the money I mean it
did well that's what I mean a lot of
other movies from the period has
background music or score aside but it
didn't and another thing I noticed you
and I don't know if I if they did this
on purpose but there ended I mean it's a
ginormous house it's just this huge huge
huge pile and they're in these big huge
rooms and when they talk their voices
don't echo yeah
and I said I wonder did they do that on
purpose like to make it seem more
claustrophobic I'm gonna you know what I
mean I don't know if that's what they
did if they did that on purpose or if
that was just how they did the sound but
I was like it's actually very effective
yeah
but basically so they're going to
investigate this house now there's kind
of a slow buildup
crazy [ __ ] that happens they do like a
what do you felt like kind of a seance
or like a city at first sittings in
reading yeah with Florence at first like
the first night they get there and she
manifests a different voice that's
telling them to get out I don't want to
have to kill you and all this other kind
of stuff and that is kind of elusive
yeah that's kind of freaky for some
reason and I think I put this on one of
the YouTube comments on one of the other
videos about our EVP show I was like for
some reason something that's always
creeps me out in movies is people
talking in other people's voices yeah
well that that actual little monologue
that she did while she was esthe that
was actually sampled by Skinny Puppy and
that was used yeah and honestly I think
that was her voice they just distorted
it as we slowed it down or something
yeah it's just very funny sounding
lowered it about three octaves yeah but
so that has always freaked me out
and also in a movie if someone's talking
in their normal voice and then all of a
sudden their voice changes there's you
know like the part in The Shining where
Danny's like Red Rock oh that used to
freak me the [ __ ] out I've got like
Simon oh I don't know why that freaks me
out there was and there's that part too
and in Who Framed Roger Rabbit
where judge doom at then where you find
out that he's a tune spoiler alert
when you thought he was a human the
whole time and he's just like don't you
remember me whatever his name was he's
like when I killed your brother but he
had like the tune boys and I'm like oh
[ __ ] no no no I don't know why that
scares me so much but it does know
German yeah I don't know why it just
freaks me out but yes oh yes oh over the
course of it like so she has also some
kind of poltergeist activity kind of
[ __ ] happening in a room like her door
opens and closes by itself there's like
breezes she hears voices like talking to
her I don't know if it's out loud or
position her mind or whatever so she
kind of comes to the conclusion that not
only is Belasco haunting the house but
that there's another ghost who was
trapped there who for some reason I mean
she thinks it's Belasco's son now I
don't know if the movie ever implied
that they knew that Velasco really did
have a son or if she just pulled that
out of her ass or what right it gets in
the same kind of situation that is very
common like in the series of haunting
where there's a chief ghost and then
he's got a whole bunch of prisoner goes
right that's what their that's what she
kind of comes to believe and she kind of
comes to believe that I mean at first I
think she thinks that it's just Daniel
Belasco and that he's just scared and
that he was victimized by his father in
life and he can't leave you know but and
then this whole time like Lionel is
being kind of a bitch-ass about him
being like no it's just nothing it's
just like a bunch of random energy it's
not a surviving personality and they're
kind of at each other's throats
now we also find out that Roddy McDowall
really he should be doing sittings along
with Florence he should be trying to
earn his money yet he's not doing it but
he's not doing anything because he has
decided one he's already been through
this [ __ ] and he doesn't want it but he
needs the money so he said well I'm just
going to sit in this house for a week
closed myself off psychically and not do
anything yeah cash my check and get the
[ __ ] out of Dodge yeah on a side note as
each day passes it has what day it is
and the time yeah and it's in the date
and the use exact same font that they
use it in the shining it does look like
that I think that's where Stanley
Kubrick got that out and I'm a throat
unless there was a like a lot of movies
doing that back then I don't know why
but yeah it was funny to submersed got
that yeah the first time I saw that I
was like I just like the shiny but that
yes exactly same thing like at the
bottom the screen telling you the day
and the time and everything like that
like I said so all the psychics kind of
at each other's throats and then Lionel
gets mad at Roger McDowell's he's like
you're blocking yourself off and George
is wasting a third of his money because
you're just sitting around not doing
anything and not helping and all this
other kind of [ __ ] he gets pissed you of
course you know yes you know Ronny
Mandela's going to get pissy yeah and
yet do his voice or I would yeah I can't
believe you can't do Roddy McDowall good
I can't do it either
and then it comes to a thing where the
kind of poltergeist activity sort of
ramps up and it seems like a lot of is
directed at Lionel so Lionel starts to
believe that Florence that the spirits
in the house will he doesn't believe in
spirits but Roddy McDowall starts
believe the spirits in the house
rolling Florence that they're working
through her we said Brad McDowell is
doing this day things l know what's the
name of this character
you forgot did you uh Fisher Fisher yeah
well I do that bitter changeable you
know the eigenvalue it's interesting on
an exam playing himself
roddy mcdowall right medium medium and
parapsychologist yet who investigated
hell house and live to tell the tale
yeah okay so Lionel starts to get mad
because he thinks that Florence is being
used by the energy now is to attack him
so there's all these arguments is like
you know you need to leave and Florence
is like no you need to leave and don't
throw this ghost on me don't throw that
psyche again it's like a bunch of stiff
fighting each other it is kind of yet
and then so Lionel's wife and she kind
of gets caught in the middle of it all
to now she gets possessed also yeah and
the ghost all of a sudden she gets
interest turned her into a real
interesting like okay so her husband who
seems like not really all that exciting
to be honest yeah he's an older guy
who's quite stick-in-the-mud
yeah so he keeps falling asleep early
and she's trying to enter night down
she's like hey bleeping I think he's
about 45 46 the actor and the actress is
playing his wife is about what 22 sep 25
what hot is hell yeah so she's kind of
like oh well and then she starts seeing
things like the kind of bestiality sort
of statues and they're like she sees the
shadows moving and she's like she's
gonna be all sad feelings I gonna move
yeah so she goes what to move on Roddy
McDowall
well yeah cuz he's the only other
marinara psychologist rather I got at a
physical oh yeah yeah given I don't know
if he was straight but he was giving me
the gay vibes at the time cuz he was
turning her down remember yeah well
maybe he thought she won't he knew she
was possessed yeah he's like I don't
want to get into be honorable about it
yeah I guess so she came down the stairs
and she's like hey let's all have an
orgy
you me that girl watching sweaty
fighting yeah and he's like no no and
everyone and everyone in the audience is
like what well he's not about her she
was doing drunk yeah yeah I like this
idea I subscribe to your newsletter yeah
and then she throws a robe off and she
says yeah so Roddy McDowall who's you
know he's a good guy think he just
immaculate molested them detainee statue
to which he was saying that she was
doing she the bull when she first came
she came down the stairs like all
seductive like yet a rabbit and [ __ ]
yeah and then the the fabulous kitty
statue yes she's kinda over there going
look at this she was appreciating the
art and there was generally a decoder to
anyone and I like how proud the statue
was it that's probably the sentiment
proudly presenting Jack you should wrote
the book on that we thought about I know
I was just gonna say okay yeah well we
went off on like a whole you know a
whole thing just yet is this movie roof
okay so yeah she she gets possessed
everyone gets to this okay so I have to
say the resolution of this it didn't
occur to me at the time but it's strange
like I don't know why it's just the
whole thing of it when you think about
it it's kind of weird right now
spoiler alert like I said now if you
haven't seen it you should have turned
it off by now and if you haven't it's
your fault okay so you're gonna be mad
do the one filming a minute that's right
miss Kokomo okay so after all this
happens they find a body like behind a
wall like chained behind a wall skeleton
so Florence is like in your face
parapsychology boys like see I told you
that's Daniel and he's in here and all
we have to do is bury him and give them
give them a proper funeral and stuff
like that in it everything will be fine
[ __ ] hope oh we're not telling that
I've gotta bury they tell the Popo about
nothing right what is Debra Branch
equivalent of the Popo
I don't know the Bobo but the thing is
is that that thing that house had been
sealed up for at least 20 years yeah
that body looks pretty fresh to me it's
still kind of her mom up ahead
it had meat on it though rotten meat on
it yeah that should have all been gone I
think it went well it was sealed up
maybe I don't know maybe well yeah you
know what a fake humidity and that was
20 years at the time of the sealing is
that they sealed it up yeah maybe the
time of the murder might have been a
decade before that yeah that's true okay
so because I think the house they said
the house was built in 1919 1990 I don't
remember I don't remember what time they
said Velasco down well they didn't say
Velasco died they said he disappeared
disappeared yeah yeah they found it
well yeah but yeah so they did find a
body so they so they take Daniel out
they give him a funeral out in the yard
and you know that from then everything
supposed to be fine but then the
haunting continues and then this at this
point is when Flores figures out oh well
maybe Velasquez and she's and he's
keeping Daniel here he's keeping the
other ghosts here trapped and that's why
burying him didn't do any good and now
she's kind of a dummy because evidently
the ghost quote-unquote comes to her in
the night and says hey if you let me
[ __ ] you then I'll be free and I have
the strength to be free right way to
justice Jesus Christ you think you know
you hear that from a living person
you're like oh [ __ ] you yeah well why'd
you hear from a ghost and you're like
what she sounds legit she was eight
naive young Christian girl she's us okay
okay I give up
yeah and guess what happens she gets the
best use of this like totally possessed
although she still is kind of fighting
it because sometimes she'll be like
talking in his voice and like I liked
her better possessed actually she was
kind of rad to that [ __ ] her hair was
all messy and sounds inept in a chair
you could have stripped with me yeah
yeah poor McDowell she calls Roddy
McDowall a bet I know you only get in
the [ __ ] end of this yeah and all the
ways were chasing him and he couldn't do
anything about
right when it comes to the end and
Lionel is like okay well I'm going to
turn on my ghost busting energy
neutralizing machinima to reverse the
polarity yeah that's the thing that and
yes pretty much that it pretty much says
I'm gonna be dead reverse the polarity
and then he said something very similar
that's kind of like a universal doctor
who it is yeah that's why I left yeah
hand me the sonic screwdriver let me
reverse the polarity yeah give me let's
turn on to whatever technology and we're
going to neutralize the ghost addition
basically yes so that's basically what
this machine does then so he's like okay
well we're going to turn it on and just
and then we're going to leave the house
and then it'll be fine
so forints who still does not believe
that this machine shoot is going to work
and she's also possessed and she's also
kind of possessed she tries to destroy
the machine yeah well in the lamest way
possible she broke the dials yeah she
will she picks up like a fireplace
pokers and she starts to try to wreck
yeah which I guess was the ghost doing
that yeah so it didn't work yeah she but
she broke like two was a little dial
windows and I'm just like wah-wah you
know I mean yeah the parapsychologist
guy said would you no good thing that
she didn't know what to break yeah so
you know then he's like just sit over
there with you know be good now while
they're [ __ ] around trying to fix the
machine
florence gets up and she goes into the
chapel and then she looks like she has
like a revelation like she figures
everything out like oh my god yeah I
remember creditors calling her wasn't it
yeah yeah she heard a voice calling her
and she goes there she sees it and then
the big crucifix with the goat Jesus on
it
I which I think maybe was just a funny
one I think it was Jenna my baby sister
file I can do this I don't know I didn't
notice anything like good you know a
really unusual or satanic about it it
just was a crudely yeah Jesus okay
whatever but yeah so she goes in there
and it falls on her yeah and crushes the
lower half of her body
yeah so as she's dying she's laying
there's blood running everywhere as
she's dying she dipped her finger in the
blood and draws a little symbol yes like
a circle with a B and I circle with a B
in it yeah and then she dies so then all
the other ones spider they're like oh
[ __ ] and
you just kind of leave her there yeah
again no Coco or Bobo or whatever no
they don't they call no one yeah so they
just kind of leave her there like ah
that's a goddamn shame she oh yeah the
prosecutor will understand
yeah whatever shit's haunted you know
just do what you got to do so there's a
little cute proto goth girl all crumpled
up underneath a huge crucifix blood
drying up yeah so they continue the
investigation yeah they're just like
well we got [ __ ] to do you know we don't
got time for that
they bring her out he left her face but
this and they were named I mean they
were kind of sad but they were just like
oh well like not we got it we got to
continue to we got to turn on the
machine your own machine and drain this
place yeah we had a plan we can't let a
death get in the way of our experiment
your episode [ __ ] to do right so they go
in and basically he's like okay well
we're going to turn the machine on and
it should only take a few minutes you
know and we have to go outside for some
reason I guess it's like when you tent
your house for termites yeah I think my
god it's like everything it's like we
can't be Andy I want to be around as
electroplate we don't know what will
happen your head will explode just like
it scanners out no stress so they turn
the machine on it's like whoa and then
they go outside and they stand dick
around for a little while annoying on TV
said it's you know in the meantime they
kind of show the inside of the house and
it's like 1:00 and there's like there's
kind of like all this vibration
happening in the house and you kind of
get like voices like oh [ __ ] oh you know
what I mean not like that not cheesy but
you know what I mean and so then they're
silent and then they go back inside the
house yeah metallic trans check it out
and Roddy McDowall finally opens himself
up to the house world-famous
parapsychologist rotting again that's
right you would still come to the
psychic man I don't know it's there I
don't believe it it's clear yeah he's
like you shouldn't work well I was
missing was the damn gorilla mask
another chimpanzee mass pity if I could
Photoshop that on yeah yeah
Isaiah yes dr. Zaius says that the house
is clear yes okay and he's like I can't
believe that machine works I really
didn't I thought I called it a piece of
junk and all this other stuff you know
because he was a psychic medium - he
believed it so they had kind of butted
heads about that also so he was like wow
it works in blah blah and they
some bad [ __ ] happens did you know it
couldn't just end like that like the end
you know right okay so then dr. Lionel
Barrett is looking at his machine being
like I'm a genius kind of thing you know
what I mean I solved parapsychology yeah
and then the machine starts like the
dials are going up and it's like whoa
and he's like oh and he's like I don't
accept that that I was like well you got
a year supposed to be a scientist and
everything like that what wait like the
Machine doesn't blow up does it look no
they won't went into the chapel or
something fell on him well he first went
like a bunch of shits are flying around
and then he somehow ended up in the
chapel I think they showed him like why
he went in there Roddy McDowall and the
wife well they wouldn't knowing into the
room and all the [ __ ] is all like all
his [ __ ] is all over the place and he's
like red line will go and then they go
in the chapel and guess where Lionel is
he did yeah big [ __ ] chandelier
chandelier with candles got a fell on
him and squished up yeah in the chapel
we see I think that they had to check
the end I remember correctly they were
checking the entire house and it was all
clear except right except for the chapel
was yeah like when they went into the
chapel and they found they found Lionel
dead and then Roddy McDowall figures in
a parapsychologist yeah he's like wow
the whole house is clear except for here
and why is that so he starts working it
out in his head
although how he figured this out it'll
be from from the clues provided I have
no idea if it is that just strange
it's levity this is what I meant when I
said this is such a strange premise well
what he wanted to be said he said and
it's making because it makes sense the B
the B inside the circle she's just
telling us that it's just Belasco there
is no other good there are no other guy
said it was just the last a whole time
pretending to be other guy which goes
back to that which in fine yeah that's
really common we say that all time when
we're talking about these haunting
episodes yeah yeah there's they're
saying it's 50 ghosts but yeah what's
the likelihood and right I agree that's
just one ghost in personating all like I
understand how he got bad because she
did draw her psychologist
is more likely and here's what this is
what I'm talking about
I'm not talking about the part where he
saw the symbol with to be in it because
that makes sense
good because you said because they had
just had a conversation like the
previous day that she would say Oh
Belasco is controlling all the ghosts
like a general with his army shred so I
understand that when he saw that symbol
that she had drawn in her blood oh she's
saying that Belasco is the only one from
he was just pretending to be that one
that makes sense what kills me and what
I'm like this is a super leap and I
don't know how he figured this out he
looks at Florence whose little legs have
been squished yeah he looks at Lionel
who's playing little Florence cute
little Florence with their choice was
not quite so cute with this course like
okay alright you have everything and
then looks at decidedly uncute Lionel
also loves and then he remembers act
right then he remembers back to all the
other people that were on the
investigation that he was on before that
he was the only one to get out of like
with his sanity intact and he's like all
of those people's injuries were leg
related yes all their legs were crushed
like they broke their ankles they broke
their shins that were crippled all these
other kind of stuff this room so he
figures out that
Emeric Belasco was not a [ __ ] just a
real short but short because here's the
thing Emeric Belasco like I said they
don't say this in the movie but I think
the implication was that he was kind of
insecure little loser type dude like he
was a bastard and all this other kind of
stuff yeah I was a rich industrialist
his mother was evidently a floozy yeah
that type of thing and he was born with
an ugly face that looked like a demon
and that they called him a laughing
giant they just explode from the roaring
giant roaring giant but mcdowell world
famous pair of psycho
figures out that really what it was just
that he must have been very short yeah
because yeah because so much Arabs
attack so much of Belasco's ego yeah was
tied up in him being this imposing gun
big guy he supposed to be six foot five
and he had this really ugly demon
looking face I don't they don't I mean
when they show him the lies were normal
he's just normal looking but um I think
so much of his ego was Ted because he
was so insecure he was trying to like
projected saying
so since Roddy McDowall famous medium
fingers the head out he's like well he
must have been super short why would my
be yeah so he starts yelling at Velasco
like challenging the ghost like how sure
are you [ __ ] like that kind of
stuff and Velasco gets mad like just
like you do when you get like you really
got gift enough to get to the ghost
[ __ ] fight yeah you know there's
another thing why no mano-a-mano ideas
right no a ghost oh right exam yeah so
sea stars yellow Glasgow black it was
like doing all the paranormal check you
get into a wind fight with the gun and
do it win but it was just a long okay
and then all right world right and right
I know them okay shut up to the end o
XIV is if you keep was because you keep
interrupting and then you're messing it
up alright you keep messing on what you
thought ing and is longer than this and
I was talking about yeah it is so if
anyway so they have the wind fight
everything like that and then Sheamus
media brawny McDowell he puts his little
hands and I said like and then the the
what he called the stained glass window
behind where the cross was it freak she
puts her hand her hands up to her head
like you guys what you can see it okay
you can see me doing it they can imagine
so then so they go through the window
and they find a room back there and
Emeric Belasco was sitting in there he's
just sitting in a chair holding the
glass of wine chilling the funk out his
excess he was brandy and I ran dear when
I went here here's the thing that I was
like wait a minute
that's where friend evaporated when that
evaporated however longing some years
yeah yeah he's really he looks like he's
alive well I mean he is alive because
it's an actor but I mean but he's not
he's like preserved right and he's just
sitting there like hey and then Roddy
McDowall pulls out of pocket pulls out a
pocket knife and stabs him in the leg
yeah
his pant leg how's his pant leg open and
shows that he's got prosthetic leg he's
got prosthetic legs because he was such
a shorty and he was so insecure about it
he cut his legs off and put on work and
walked around with prosthetic legs and
make himself super tall right yeah I'm
pretty sure it God I don't think I can
get that is the cure I don't know what
the hell's wrong with that is some
massive I think overweight I think
they're all a guy wrote that story short
guys don't think I wonder have tell
Richard Matheson is yeah I'll get that
out see I guess I'm like who would even
think if I would not be look at that no
I would not think of that I'm five six I
don't I don't think that why everything
that velasca was like under five feet
tall yeah he must have been like listen
he's I'd worn even five feet tall yeah
and then he got like yeah like you're
hurting my family shut up I'm super tall
but you know what I mean so it was like
that so then the kicker of the movie
they said okay so the medium Floris
Tanner and the parapsychology are both
kind of right because the reason why the
Machine hadn't completely worked was
because the room that Velasco had sealed
his body into was lined with lead
so somehow Belasco knew many years like
twenty years or thirty years or however
long ago was he died that some
[ __ ] would come in there with a
ghost neutralizing machine and
neutralize his go so he's like I'm I'm
going to forestall that scenario and I'm
just going to put lead in here and I'm
just going to sit in here with my brandy
until I until somebody walks in and
freaks out sees me well world-renowned
parapsychologist realized that he knew
the future but I really have what I
think it was it was just a wise wizard
like Belasco would know that you know
your [ __ ] should be red line for good
magic line it was that it make it a lot
better be good good maybe I felt what
there is just totally just total
[ __ ] yes - okay so they leave so
they leave that room open then they turn
the machine on again and so now the
whole house is cleared out supposedly so
the only people that lived were roddy
mcdowall same
medium and parapsychologist and the wife
of the douchey physicist / /
psychologist who died by getting crushed
and the house still stood so you know
that left that left it open for a sequel
but they never made one now they might
make a remake at some point but just
look at a present I'm sure they will
yeah there's something about what
seventies Dada has there put CG well see
now that's what happened when they
remade the haunting from 1963 they
remade it in 1999 was like Catherine
zeta-jones and Owen Wilson and shredder
and that [ __ ] [ __ ] soft oh my god the
cool thing about the original movie was
that they didn't really show anything
but it was still creepy but then the
remake it was just let's put big let's
make the bed her into the fighter and
let's like put all these big and green
ghost fly driver the stupidest [ __ ]
[ __ ] ever it made me so angry so that
was the legend of Hell house and like I
said there's really haunted house movies
of the 70s I don't know what it is but
they just kind of have this sort of
overarching art of what it is it's like
some kind of weird feeling about them
that make them just creepier than new
ones I don't know why what is that I
don't well I remember seeing when I was
a kid you and I always had the feeling
of like some of the bad that's going to
happen
you weren't really sure what state of
the art was so yeah sure yeah that's
what we were talking about of you yeah
you know so I think the first one that I
saw that actually not only did it
threaten to show you stuff in that way
it also showed you stuff that it [ __ ]
if that was the evil yeah that was about
what 1980
yeah there's 80 or 81 something like I
had enough enough technology to just
shock you pretty bad yeah and really
legend of Hell House I mean it shows
things moving around like it shows stuff
being moved are like poultry type
activity it shows like a creepy seance
where she produces ectoplasm
but other than it doesn't show any
ghosts it doesn't at all implication
yeah it's kind of like a medieval [ __ ]
a medieval kind of like that if you look
at a medieval horror today that's like a
made-for-tv movie yeah I'd be like a
made-for-tv movie today we just wouldn't
but in scared people in the back in the
day well now there's really nothing well
honestly sometimes we'll depending on
how it's done I think movies that don't
show a lot can be potentially scary the
ones that do
because I think imagining things is
worse than seeing that because sometimes
if you show something you're just like
men I go this one big this one is a lot
more graphic than a medieval [ __ ] it is
yes that's true even though it's over
yeah and the evil that movie shows even
more yeah they're all good it's a
different style yeah but yeah I
definitely recommend a legend of Hell
house if you haven't seen if you like
70s haunted house movies it's one of my
favorites I also want to do burnt
offerings one of these days which is
kind of similar yeah you guys you got
wound up on this one I love this man
yeah you guys excited to exciting you're
so yeah it is that thing all right
that'll do it for this is our fourth
movie review isn't it yeah something
like that yeah we'll definitely do some
more in the future and I hope you guys
are liking these we are having a good
time doing them and we'll see you guys
next time bye